Je veux vous parler d'un homme que j'ai connu une fois,
il a laissé toute sa vie sous un grand
scanner en mouvement, alors il a quitté sa
maison au sommet de la terre et il
est venu dans le sud pour que le reste d'entre nous
vive J'ai un message important  attends,
laisse-moi prendre ça de ton haut ton nom
est Teddy se sent sur une mission de Dieu de
mes aînés à propos de la fin du monde nous
dans le sud faisons de très mauvaises
choses et le soleil a eu un coup de pied alors
il descend le bus dont
j'ai besoin  parler à vos aînés
parler à tous les dirigeants du monde
c'est le moi intérieur mr.  tes neuf
écoeurants
[Musique]
tu ne peux pas aller dans ce joint ressemblant à
un Esquimau auquel nous voulons nous adapter
suis-je en train d'être filmé
[Musique]
J'ai entendu ton histoire sur le Soleil et je l'ai
trouvée fascinante ces ici ici
viennent juste de sauver le monde nous '  Je recherche des
entreprises qui veulent parrainer un événement
que l'OHP a organisé, il est temps pour une
révolution une révolution de l'esprit et
bien je dois dire que vous avez un impact considérable avec
cette histoire,
ils ne pensent pas à ce qu'ils
ne peuvent pas faire, ils '  je pense à ce
qu'ils peuvent vous inspirer
pourquoi êtes-vous si intéressé par ce gars je
vois l'innocence et le but
je n'ai pas cru en quoi que ce soit depuis
trop longtemps
[Musique]
Oh non